5 ap Japan render spar ii is g pearl beads 3 blue
do
hi to do
as is reborn
no
negi rus aroa reapers Mare ga
[music]
Roaster director and chief executive officer Hiromi Okubo c
5 Coffee is 100 yen  I think you've seen a lot of them, but I
'm pursuing crazy anyway. For
delicious coffee, I'm blending 50% of the first coffee with 50% to make it a massage
surface.
ond agentur sterben Jet That's the point that you can
get
it for
100 yen the most, because you buy it with raw beans, it costs 100 yen
.
Iced coffee is a.
Since the machine is
hot, it extracts, but the
tank is cooled by the time it falls,
and it is a machine that makes iced coffee in a state of rapid cooling
. Japanese people can not let go of coffee anymore.
Those who can come two or three times will also be quite like
4 abb.
I'm doing it.
caso wedding stores
are you
and if you do ah
[music]
noas worker panty 5 j 5
neon 2 wheels 4 wheels lantern pony zoom shield wing professional sports
Tsukishita
paura king fem
iphone 4 s perse
Lone star Ranno back  Ka
+ card geran
h email share minutes
voodoo
anone Zu hd
Which mother is Onani Koumie Crispe Plan
Well, at general youth tier 25 Kanachi-Caution
Ramen to do
I'm Wataru Yoshida I'm a municipal coffee elementary school I'm with a teacher  I've been
sharing a super school for 21 years before I got into this profession.
I'm looking at a popular coffee polar wrestler.
I've come to the times, but I
'm making a menu with Japanese attendance so that the children who taught me have become university student students and I feel a little nostalgic
. Today's
coffee is not good at coffee.  It's my blend that I made because I wanted to create a taste that both people who like it and those who like it would be satisfied with
.
The floor is
blended and grinded with a slightly more perforated effect than medium
grind so that it comes out well but not too much. It
smells like blueberries or has a sweet scent.
I will provide it in a special cup for you.
Now I have a wife who can enjoy the scent so that the flowers can enter here and enjoy the scent,
so do not stir there
[Music]
windows  8 pro Difficult Cap sa Chop
Noru Faio Hauu ameblomaster Already Day
cesaire Tebekyu Time Vanger
Boo Boo starborn Harding espar pdt to do
usp deore arap the voodoo Booing Bailey
voodoo
Blueberry paperman
releasenote Api Sweets paint works
Space this are you doing
[Music]
voodoo
border Winker Re
My name is Tanaka Feeling The name of the store is Mu and
I drink coffee, etc.
Aged sample coffee 20 years
yd Last night Interfe I'm there
Spartan name
I made it and kept it in the coffee for a long time,
but I forgot it and
it was in the back of the coffee about Sancha seeds
.  It's a waste
, so even if I drink it, I won't die even if I'm hungry. If I drink it, I'm
not an
intern.
I wonder if it will be 7 dora after putting it in the
coffee.  Roses isn't it? First of all, the old beans have been
asleep for about 20 years.
By controlling it
, it's time to grind it into small pieces.
e
Going Rotos is the 6th last, because the
neutrality is a distant sign, Amamiya, and the 20-year-old that the miscellaneous taste disappears.
This is only the best part of this kind of extract. This is rom Poi
Weber swelling version Jetters brother Enka Parker fever in flowers
are you do
screaming good
re re re re you doing
[music]
cuff in casa is m  There are 10 days to infiltrate
4 f secure the voodoo as ah
Jankenton
first listener
pou dou dou
[music]
yeah
refer to do
[music]
4 arenberg jp That's
voodoo
yeah
5 minutes
right side
[music]
voodoo Case
voodoo
Mighty my paper You should remember this
[Music]
voodoo
Scarface Range? 3 turns
Safely remember
Ai new uo Hot water phase Made of cable
Prostar
border to do
5 oes Good